il faut qu'on soit tous lucides et
reconnaissants de ce qui ne va pas
partout ça ne va pas donc pas commencé
par dénoncer les causes être factuel
objectif sur ce qui se passe et ne pas
imaginer que c'est parce qu'il ya une
violence d'un côté que ça justifie celle
de l'autre parce que on est dans une
espèce de cycle schizophrène une spirale
moi ce que je dénonce dans ce livre vous
l'avez vu ça a parfois étonné c'est
autant la haine des bourgeois vis-à-vis
des forces de l'ordre par leur
condescendance que la haine de ceux qui
haïssent les flics pour d'autres raisons
tout le monde est responsable de ça et
si on reste dans cet engrenage là on va
jamais en sortir et le but c'est essayer
de progresser c'est ce que j'essaye en
tout cas de montrer dans le livre ça
c'est le premier point je pense que j'ai
vu là un chapiteau qui brûle on est tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est stupide
c'est tout le monde qui en est victime
et le chapiteau n'est plus accessible on
a vu ces violences urbaines l'a
récemment elles n'ont pour cause unique
qu'un jeu entre cité des yvelines si
toutefois c'est la cause parce que moi
je reste toujours prudent je le dis dans
le livre
la plupart des violences urbaines sont
parfois gratuite donc ça à la limite ça
se traite c'est l'éducation
on peut tous faire quelque chose ça moi
j'ai souvent dit quand on est dans les
réunions quartier moi j'ai fait que de
la banlieue ou du quartier difficile ou
du commissariat de sécurité publique
j'ai fait le métier qui est celui auquel
on est dédié pour la population je suis
jamais sortie d'une réunion de quartier
du goudron et des plumes cantons
s'expliquent avec les gens c'est parfois
engagés c'est parfois on n'est pas
d'accord mais on a toujours eu du
dialogue les gens ont l'impression si
nous regarder science mais à s'engueuler
ou à s'invectiver qu'on n'a pas de
dialogue c'est faux en revanche j'ai des
problèmes faut pas les nier c'est pas
les violences policières qui ont emmené
les violences dans les banlieues
urbaines et c'est pas les violences
urbaines qui compte les policiers sont
devenus violents
c'est des problématiques beaucoup plus
complexe de formation d'éducation donc
si on est tous capables de reconnaître
les choses police inclus c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire non pas au nom de la
police mais en tant que représentant un
policier parmi d'autres on peut
progresser donc je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire
moi je vous ai écoutés mais on n'est pas
prudent quand on dit la police on a
l'impression qu'elle devrait qu'elle
aurait dû être condamné on parle d'
affaires en cours
vous n'avez pas précisé pour la ferté
haut que les expertises disent aussi que
y'a pas violent parce qu'il n'ya pas
l'élément intentionnel une infraction
elle est qualifiée par la justice il va
laisser à l'anus qui perfore un colon
oui mais ça c'est l'effet l'erreur
ariel vous avez des fois je veux urgence
des gens qu'ils m'expliquent est
attribué sur une bouteille avec la
bouteille est rentré dans l'anus par
magie là je suis désolé lorsque
j'entends qu'on me dit une matraque
télescopique qui rentre dans la nuit qui
perfore quelqu'un me dire qu'il ya pas
de sentiment un intentionnel et ça ça
énerve les gens il faut qu'il faut il
faut le reste léger ce qui peut les
énervés et pourquoi il faut pas qu'ils
s'énervent qui dit ça dans la procédure
ce sont des experts mandatés par la
justice ça n'est pas la police qui dit
ça ce sont des experts ils sont
indépendants
il y en a plusieurs et peut y en avoir
encore d'autres si la famille le demande
ou si la partie civile le demande si les
parquets le demander car dans la sphère
adama traoré y de multi z autopsie à
chaque fois une nouvelle version
apparaît où il explique qu'il est mort
initialement d'une infection pulmonaire
mais ensuite une sarcoïdose avec une
drépanocytose il aurait fait ce qu'on
appelle un syndrome thoracique aiguë un
truc rarissime parce que finalement il
ne savait pas qu'il était malade et donc
tout ça les gens qui vous qui voit les
différentes expertises parce qu'à chaque
fois on parle de mort de gens qui sont
morts ou qui vont être gravement mutilés
et ben ça dans la population notamment
dans les banlieues s'est pas compris
d'où le fait qu'on parle de haine
et lorsque vous dites là il y avait des
émeutes et le truc du cirque c'est
complètement débile c'est un jeu mais
messi briscards et je n'ai cessé ses
suppliques il faut le dénoncer il faut
éduquer vous avez bien dit mais les
émeutes après zyed et bouna de banlieue
qu'on a eue c'était sentiment de haine
de révolte mais ça on peut la voir à
nantes l'année dernière rappelez-vous ce
jeune homme qui a reçu une balle dans la
carotide
ils étaient dans une voiture et il est
mort ensuite j'ai suivi quelques jours
de haine et d'émeutes qu'on peut
comprendre parce qu'on se dit que des
vies sont brisées et des gens sont aussi
par par dont vous parlez aussi de tous
les policiers ce plus de 55 par jour qui
sont blessés policiers et gendarmes
est ce qu'on peut parler aussi de plus
de 50 suicides dans la police de fin
d'année 54,5
est ce à quoi me parlait aussi du
sentiment aujourd'hui des policiers de
peur au ventre
lorsqu'ils sortent de chez eux ou
lorsque leur nom est jeté en pâture sur
les réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'on peut parler aussi tout ça
ou alors est ce qu'on parle seulement de
certaines victimes via des victimes lui
a des problèmes mais comprend la haine
entre et y fixer la cautionner non la
cautionner
c'est l'excusé est là en rendant un
système totalement d'inversion des
valeurs
qu'est ce qu'on dit aux enfants qu'on
peut avoir la haine de ceux qui nous
protège qu'est ce qu'un policier qu'est
ce qu'un gendarme
ce sont des gens qui se lèvent tous les
matins pour nous protéger c'est pas
seulement les gens qui font de la
répression il faut quand même remettre
les choses dans
bon ordre on est totalement là avec les
gelées et jaune qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on a mis toute une masse de la
population qui s'est mis à détester les
flics mais rappelons-nous la presse
après charlie tout à coup on adorait la
police maintenant on la déteste on à la
population contre la police mais ça
c'est très grave
est ce que c'est être contre la police
c'est être contre les institutions c'est
perdre tous nos repères toutes nos
valeurs on peut pas être contre la
police contre la justice
donc faudrait agir mais il ya des
procédures 11 heures et à force
d'attiser comme ça les choses
eh ben on se rend compte que c'est
l'inversion c'est les policiers
maintenant qu'ils ont peur les policiers
manon les fûts plus on les affronte on
les attaquait des émeutes
et ça c'est complètement inacceptable